a six-part disney plus original series
will smith steps out of a red suv i've
got a confession to make words appear
over a blue and green spear from
national geographic
i've never climbed a mountain will
repels down a volcano academy award
nominee darren aronofsky never swum in a
lake academy award nominee will smith
i was in a cave once
will stands on a boat staring out at the
vast ocean
i'm beginning to think that i might be
missing something well ready yes sir in
a small plane will fist bumps a man i
ask the best modern-day explorers take
me to the ends of the earth
and they said oh we can go further than
that
three two
one a submarine's lights extinguish
plunging them into darkness let's see
what's out there
fluorescent fish float by
we think we know our planet white water
kayaking but there's still a secret
world to be discovered
if you go to the right place with the
right guide you just might find a portal
into it
and we need to helm it because the
volcano spits rocks up in the air
as if
this helmet is going to do something
we're one of these big rocks
the starlet sky ships i sure hope you
know where you're going i hope so too
they traverse ice
see hear feel the planet i almost
guarantee you're gonna survive
like never before an suv descends a
steep sand dune
i thought you were gonna freak out but
you just kept going i'm an actor i
pretend for a living a scuba diver
enters water a whale swims by wildebeest
stampede
that's spectacular this is a bucket list
moment
an object explodes will and a man high
five a scuba diver examines coral orcas
pass a kayak sandstorms whip against
will a river thunders through a canyon
my grandmother used to say all the best
things in life lived on the other side
of fear will rides a zipline i sure hope
gigi was right white letters appear over
an earth-like sphere of flowing liquid
welcome to earth